Now, ladies and gentlemen,
most of you already know
that the Democratic Convention
is going on right now
in Chicago, it's a big deal.
And Andy and I wanted very much to attend,
but as you know, we
don't have a lot of time.
You know, our time is a
very precious commodity.
Right, Kyle would be sitting here alone.
Exactly.
If we had gone there.
Right, exactly so what we
did is we decided to send
our very own foam rubber
Conan and Andy instead
'cause they're just as good.
Now, I've been told we're
still having a couple
of audio problems with foam rubber Andy,
but I understand they're
hardly noticeable.
So here they are, folks, the
foam rubber Conan and Andy
in Chicago, hiya fellas.
[Foam Rubber Conan] We're in
between speakers right now,
but man alive, this is a
lot of fun, huh Andy, huh?
This is unbelievable.
(Andy moaning)
We are here, man, woo!
Right here, I'm on the floor!
I'm just standing here,
it's a great turnout.
I mean, there's a lot of people here.
A lot of 'em involved in politics,
and I think that's great.
But we wanna show you some
of the stuff we've seen today
so we're gonna roll it right now, huh.
Here we go!
(Andy mumbling)
(audience laughing)
What's your name?
My name's John Olson.
[Foam Rubber Conan] John
Olson, what do you do, John?
I sell political memorability here
for political Americana
and financial innovations,
the official licensee
of the Democratic
National Convention 1996.
[Foam Rubber Conan] Can
you say that one more time.
(John stammers)
(patriotic instrumental music)
(audience laughing)
How you doing, James?
We love you, James.
How y'all doing?
[Foam Rubber Conan] Well,
that was our first interview.
(audience laughing)
If you want to see it again, here it is.
How you doing, James?
We love you, James.
How y'all doing?
(audience laughing)
[Foam Rubber Conan] Conan,
the bathroom situation here
at the convention is pretty grim.
In the hall itself
you're gonna have to wait
about a half hour in line, but thank God
for the good people at Portable John.
(audience laughing)
They've got these all over the place.
(Andy moaning)
(audience laughing)
Took you long enough, Andy.
(Andy mumbling)
Let's go, move it alone, people.
All right everybody, that's it for tonight
for Andy and I from the convention.
We'll see you tomorrow night, all right.
We're having a lot of fun
'cause it's a convention, woo!
Ow, come on man, what are you doing?
Woo, hello America!
(Andy grunts)
It's our second night
here at the convention.
Things are pretty much wrapping up now,
but we're sticking around
having a party, woo!
Andy's had a couple too many.
We tried to talk to some
people like some Democrats,
but people don't seem to be
interested, you know, right?
(Andy grunting)
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, yeah, wait, come
on man, play off, be cool.
Anyway, we're gonna
show you some highlights
from today at the convention
and so take a look.
(cheers) All right, Convention '96!
(audience applauding)
Come on, man.
(upbeat rock music)
(audience laughing and applauding)
Andy wants to ask you a question.
What do you want to ask me?
(Andy mumbling)
What?
I don't understand what he's saying.
(Andy mumbling)
What?
(upbeat rock music)
[Foam Rubber Conan] I had
no idea it was illegal?
You just put 'em up there
up against the wall.
You watch it there, pink
stuff, you watch it!
I'm watching you!
[Foam Rubber Conan] All right, all right,
take it easy, huh.
Come on, hey now!
[Foam Rubber Conan] Hey, hey, I saw that!
I got five bucks on me and
I'm itching to spend it.
Let's go drink, Andy, woo!
Chug, chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, yes!
(Andy groaning)
(audience laughing)
I think we lost Andy.
Like, 20 minutes we was in the sky box
and we were drinking and buying
and then I lost him 'cause the door shut.
I couldn't get back in
'cause it was locked.
But I'm gonna go back, now, man
'cause I know he's back at the hotel.
We're gonna party some
more at the Convention '96!
(upbeat rock music)
This is what the convention's all about.
That's right, honey.
(upbeat rock music)
(audience applauding)
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
Why, why, Andy?
I don't know.
And I think also the question
that's on all America's mind,
why is your caricature
a pink bear? (laughs)
I never knew that myself.
My brother Luke called me
this morning and was like,
"I don't understand why
Andy is a pink bear."